not going to spend a ton of time on this
but Mike Lindell is really starting to
get frustrated that Donald Trump still
hasn't been reinstated here he is on
this same program where it's his show
the Lindell report but he often calls in
as a guest in this case from a car and
he says he's got the the Royal flesh and
somehow Trump still hasn't been
reinstated and he's very frustrated
when you have when I'm sitting on those
kind of evidence we are and that I am
um and you can't it's like having a
Royal Plush in a poker game but you
can't play your hand I'm tired of it you
know you have a royal flush I want the
game to end and get back to you know in
our country back here let's get this get
this evidence out in the open for the
whole world to see and uh give Brandon
yeah
um he hasn't actually shown anyone the
evidence in his post remember last week
Mike pillow was posting all over our
Facebook page he said that the evidence
is as follows they captured packets from
China
they presented everything at the
Symposium and China was caught
red-handed not exactly an overwhelming
case here's another one of these
examples from a few days ago Lindell
said his cyber guys went through the
data and they found it they found
everything and if you listen closely
you'll probably come away saying they
found what I have really great news
um well called great news
um is four percent there's only four
percent of those counties so far that uh
cyber guys have looked at that are not
compromised in other words 96 of all the
counties we've went through already
which is hundreds of them have all been
machine manipulated yep and the and this
is a hundred percent evidence so yeah
that's it's evidence as he calls it also
another major declaration from Mike
pillow hello I'm Mike Lindell and due to
your incredible support the original my
slippers are almost completely sold out
okay so anyway I consider the uh slipper
news basically as important as his
claims there about uh about the evidence
this guy is furious that Trump hasn't
been reinstated and it's all absolutely
and completely pathetic and we're going
to watch whether anything actually ever
happens but it seems what's happening
now that his phone has been seized by
the FBI is the so-called evidence is
going to be evidence in a potential
trial against pillow then evidence that
Trump should be reinstated incredible
how the tables have turned the David
packman shows longest running sponsor is
blinkist the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils each of them
down into an explainer you can read or
listen to in 15 minutes blinkist also
condenses episodes of popular podcasts
into 15-minute explainers I've been
using blinkist for years to supplement
the books I read I love reading I read
all the time but there's even more books
I don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consumed the entire thing
in 15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkus connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkus connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below